hi everyone we are here at the 15th
anniversary of Saint Louis chess club in
Central West End it's also International
Chess Day there is a lot of fun going on
behind us let's go check that out
[Music]
today is a fantastic day so we have a
beautiful weather and then there are so
many players here even from the like U.S
junior seniors girls we are playing Dak
chat by the way you can see my face
paint and it's so fun to see all the
players yesterday is playing duck chess
even Josiah stiron Karissa everybody
here so it's really fun to to be just
experiencing chess we have a lot of kids
here we have a lot of adults a lot of
Club players so I think everybody's
really enjoying the chess atmosphere
celebrating 15th anniversary of the club
and I mean it's just really fun I think
everybody who started this formation of
the St Louis chess club it has truly
been a great advancement to the game of
chess especially in this country and I'm
just so excited to be here and play all
like just chess with other people who do
as well I'm just so happy and so elated
[Music]
wow what does a club mean to me well it
changed my life if I wasn't doing the
commentatory I'd be watching
so now I've got the best job in the
world I've got a front row seat
I get to mingle with the chess players
and I get to watch the greatest games in
the world unfold in front of me and it's
been a life changing and the most
rewarding experience my chess career
I'm 15 years older and I'm still here
it's pretty good now I see what it is I
realize we have such an incredible staff
like you guys that it's just remarkably
successful there's no question it's the
best club in the country if not the
world
[Music]
it was a wonderful day full of fun
celebration and ice cream I Just Want to
Thank You Saint Louis chess club for an
amazing 15 years happy International
Chess Day
[Music]